F
THE SPECIAL WARRIOR --
>> Greg: HOPE YOU HAD A
MARVELOUS WEEKEND I DID BUT
ACCORDING TO MY LEGAL COUNSEL
AND NEVER HAPPENED.
SEE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY WAS ON
"60 MINUTES" LAST NIGHT, I
WONDER AND SPEAKING TO TO NOTE
HE CALL THEM WEEK?
>> YOU SAID IF YOU CAN'T HELP
YOU SHOULDN'T EXIST.
NOT VERY DIPLOMATIC OF YOU, I
WONDER WHY YOU FEEL THE NEED TO
SPEAK SO BLUNTLY.
>> WHEN YOU'RE WORKING AT
DIPLOMACY THERE THERE IS NO
RESULTS.
ALL OF THIS IS VERY BUREAUCRATIC
THAT'S WHY THE WAY I AM TALKING
TO THEM IS ABSOLUTELY
JUSTIFIABLE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY MORE LIVES TO
GIVE, I DON'T HAVE EMOTIONS, I'M
NO LONGER INTERESTED IN THEIR
DIPLOMACY THAT LEADS TO THE
DESTRUCTION OF MY COUNTRY.
>> Greg: WHETHER YOU GO, WHEN
COBE FIRST BROKE OUT,
DONALD TRUMP USE THE WAR
METAPHOR, WERE FIGHTING A
DISEASE IS NO DIFFERENT THAN
YOUR.
THIS WAS TO GET AMERICA TO SHOW
THE WEAR IN THIS THING TOGETHER
AS IF IT WERE POSSIBLE TO SHARE
WITH NANCY SUE PELOSI.
JUST LIKE IN MORE TRUTH WINS
FIRST CASUALTY.
SO NOW IT SEEMS WE CAN USE COVID
AS AN ANALOGY FOR WAR.
WE WANT THE ILLNESS SPREAD?
A QUESTION HE SHOULD'VE ASKED
CNN PLUS.
[LAUGHS]
BUT ALSO DO WE WANT TO WAR TO
TURN INTO A WORLD WAR?
DO THE WORK AND SPREAD FASTER
THAN THAT RASH TO KEEP GETTING
WHEN I DON'T WIPE DOWN MY OLD
THIGH MASTER.
THAT WAS GRAPHIC.
AS WE SAW IN COVID, TEXAS CHANGE
THE INCOMING DATA CHANGES FUTURE
TACTICS I WOULD DO IN THE DATA
CORRECTLY?
DO MASKS WORK OR THEY DON'T.
THUS THE DEBATE OVER WHAT HELPS
THE UKRAINIANS.
THE LOCKDOWNS ARE THE LARGER
COMMITMENTS.
IT'S ABOUT SACRIFICE WE SEND
JETS, OR DID WE SEND BOOTS ON
THE GROUND?
SOCIAL DISTANCING?
THAT SOUND LIKE DRONES.
THEY MAY CONTACT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO.
BUT ULTIMATELY WOULD WE WANT TO
DO VERSUS WHAT DO WE DECIDE TO
DO?
IS IT ABOUT SPEEDING UP THE END
OF THE WAR, OR WINNING WAR
OUTRIGHT?
AS AN AMATEUR HISTORIAN, MEANING
I ONLY READ THE FUNNY PARTS IN
THE BOOKS.
AND AREN'T ANY.
FOR THE SAKE OF LIVES LOST HIS
ABETTOR TO IT AND WERE FAST
GIVEN THAT FEAR THAT HIS WORDS:
THEY GO ON AND THEY GO ON, THE
LONGER THEY LAST THE LESS LIKELY
THEY AND, IN AFGHANISTAN.
EVEN WHEN YOU WIN YOU LOSE.
THE AWARD DOESN'T HELP.
NOW LOOKING AHEAD AND HAVE
UKRAINIANS HAVE STYMIED RUSSIA,
THE INSTINCT IS TO KEEP GOING
AND GO FOR THE KILL.
SO WHAT ARE WE WILLING TO RISK?
HOW DO WE DEFINE WINNING?
THEY ARE LOSING IN VARIOUS
WAVES, IS VIEWED AS DESPICABLE.
AND THAT'S WITH THE SHIRT ON.
THEY ARE SEEN AS HEROIC AND THE
LOSSES INCURRED BY THE RUSSIANS
IS NO LONGER SMALL.
YOU CAN SEE THEM CHANGING THE
COURSE.
MAYBE THEY COULD BE THERE FOR
GOOD, OCCUPYING A NEW STRAIN OF
COVID AND THEN WHAT?
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH US.
IT'S SOLID WE CAN WATCH HOW IT'S
GOING BECAUSE PRETTY MUCH WORK
AND BE ONTO SOMETHING SOMETHING
ELSE.
THE MEDIA AND HAVE THE
COLLECTIVE ATTENTION SPAN OF A
GNAT ON BATH SALTS BUT I INCLUDE
MYSELF IN THAT.
ALSO WE CAN'T REALLY TELL WHO'S
WINNING, IS THAT THE PATIENT OR
THE DISEASE?
UKRAINIANS ARE WORTHY OF SUPPORT
GIVEN THEIR BRAVERY, THEY ARE
THE VICTIMS.
YOU CAN ARGUE ABOUT THE PAST AND
EVEN OUR OWN PROBABILITY THAT
RUSSIA DID INVADE AFTER ALL.
BUT THERE'S MORE SUPPORT AND
EXTEND THE WORK OR DOES IT IT?
THAT'S WHEN THE QUESTION SINCE
THE BEGINNING.
THE SANCTIONS FAILED TO BRING
THEM TO HIS KNEES, THE REAL
RUBLE IS REBOUNDING MEANING THE
SANCTIONS IS GONNA PUT THE
POOREST AT RISK.
THIS IS SOUNDING MORE LIKE
COVERT ALL THE TIME.
STILL IT MAKES SENSE TO PUNISH
VLADIMIR PUTIN BUT IS IT REALLY
TIME TO ENGAGE THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE?
DO WE LOAD THEM UP WITH THE
LATEST TECH, WE PROBABLY ARE
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO GIVE THEM
MORE.
BUT I CAN ALWAYS LEAD TO MORE
INVOLVEMENT AND MORE COMMITMENT
AND THEN THAT LEADS TO WHO KNOWS
WHAT.
SO CAN YOU HANDLE A WAR WITH
INFLATION, CRIME, AND DEMOCRATS
RUNNING WILD?
MY THINKING IS YOU SHOULD BE
RESISTING TO MEASURES EVEN AS
YOU SUGGEST THEM.
ONE THING WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS
MAKE THINGS WORSE.
BUT TELL THAT YOU UKRAINIAN
WOMAN WHO LOST HIS HUSBAND AND
KIDS TO ONE OF HIS MISSILES.
AND PAST EXPERIENCES WHEN WERE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE HAVE WORSE
THINGS CAN THIS WORK GET WORSE?
SO HOW'S THAT FOR WRITING?
I BEEN WRITING IT SO LONG I'VE
BEEN ASKED FULL OF SPLINTERS.
BUT IT CAN BE THE BEST VANTAGE
POINT WHEN MAKING DECISIONS THAT
RESULT IN DEATH, I BELIEVE IN
GROUND WARS, IT'S A THING OF THE
PAST I'D SAY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT DRONES.
WILL FIGHT THE WARS WITH
JOYSTICKS AND BASEMENTS.
SO EVEN WITH THOSE RUSSIAN
TROOPS FLOODING THE BORDER AND
PEOPLE GETTING SICK IN WUHAN, WE
STILL DIDN'T REALLY BUY IT.
THE MEDIA CRIED WOLF SO MANY
TIMES WE THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO WAKE UP.
BUT MAYBE WE WEREN'T MISTAKEN
THINKING CONVENTIONAL WAR IS
KIND OF OVER.
PERHAPS YOU ARE OVERCONFIDENT
LIKE WHEN I THOUGHT THAT
STRIPPER WAS MY GIRLFRIEND.
MAYBE UKRAINE IS ONE MODERN
EXAMPLE TO SHOW HOW GROUND WARS
DON'T WORK.
YOU SEE CRUMPLED TANKS AND
DESPERATE MILITARY, BUT WITHOUT
VISUAL EXPLANATION FOR IT.
MODERN TECHNOLOGY IS TEACHING A
VLADIMIR PUTIN THAT HE CAN
OCCUPY A COUNTRY EVEN IF HE IS
WAY BIGGER.
HOW CAN HE OCCUPY WHEN DRONES
NEVER SLEEP?
WE'RE ANNOUNCING A GROUND FORCE
AND CRUSHED BY THE OFFSPRING OF
RADIOSHACK.
IT'S NOT REALLY THAT DIFFERENT
FROM THAT REMOTE CONTROLLED RACE
GOT FOR CHRISTMAS.
INVITE A REBOOT AND DIDN'T EVEN
SEE IT COMING.
>> LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
I TURN THEM ON AT 6:00 P.M. HE
TURNS ME ON 24/7.
YET I WAS CREEPY.
SPECIAL REPORT BRET BAIER.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE IS COVERED MORE
GAMES THAN THE ROOF AT DAVE AND
BUSTER, FORMER SPORTSCASTER
MICHELE TAFOYA, GO BEARS.
[APPLAUSE]
IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANYTHING NICE
TO SAY THEN YOU PROBABLY GET
ALONG WITH HER.
FOX BUSINESS ANCHOR, DAGEN
MCDOWELL.
[APPLAUSE]
AND FINALLY SHE IS DOWN-TO-EARTH
LIKE THE ASTEROID THAT KILLED
THE DINOSAURS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
HOW YOU DOING?
>> Bret: I'M REALLY IMPRESSED
THE OF A THIGH MASTER RASH.
[LAUGHS]
THAT IS REALLY, REALLY
IMPRESSIVE.
>> Greg: I THREW THEM MY WAY
BRETT YOU KNOW I'M SAYING?
I BELIEVE ME YOU SHOULD SEE ME
ALTERNATIVE, THAT WAS THE ONE
THAT MADE THE CUT.
THERE WERE THINGS IN THEIR RIGHT
THAT WOULD MAKE YOUR SKIN CRAWL.
YES I LIKE TO LEAD THEM TO READ
THEM TO YOU AFTER THE SHOW IF
YOU DON'T MIND.
YOU WERE STILL RIGHT?
OKAY, NO GIVE THE DIRECTIONS.
AT THE SAME PLACE.
WHILE HE BLINDFOLDED SION OVER
THE HOT TUB IS.
>> Bret: OH, DEAR.
>> Greg: YOUR EVENT IN THE
NEWS BUSINESS, CAN YOU MAKE
HEADS OR TAILS IN THIS WAR IN
TERMS OF MOMENTUM?
I GO BACKWARDS AND FORWARDS.
I AM THINKING RUSSIA IS MOVING
AWAY FROM THEM THEY LOST AND
OTHER THAN HAVE TO DO ANOTHER
THING, BUT THEN I GO THEY COULD
EASILY WIN IT.
I DO KNOW WHERE TO GO.
>> Bret: IT'S REALLY TOUGH TO
SEE ON THE GROUND, WE BEEN VERY
FORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE REPORTED
TO BEEN OUT AND WE PAID A PRICE
FOR THAT AT FOX OBVIOUSLY.
YOU CAN'T SEE ALL OF THE STUFF
THAT'S HAPPENING THROUGHOUT
UKRAINE, YOU CAN SEE THAT
UKRAINIANS ONE IN KYIV COME UP
ANOTHER GOING TO THE EAST.
I THINK IT COULD JUST BE A
MATTER OF TIME WITH ZELENSKYY IN
EVERY MEDIA POSSIBLE AND THEY
TALK REALLY SLOW AND 60 MINUTES.
VERY DELIBERATE.
I NEED WEAPONS NOW, KEEP THIS
GOING, KEEP THIS MOMENTUM.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
YOU CAN'T SAY WHO'S GONNA WIN.
>> Greg: IS JUST UNKNOWABLE
UNTIL IT HAPPENS.
AND THEN I DO KNOW AND THEN
PEOPLE CAN SAY I KNOW IS CAN
HAPPEN.
WE FALL INTO THESE ANALOGIES AND
THERE IS ALMOST LIKE A GOODY
WITH A PORTABLE DOUBLE QUESTION
THE SPORTS ANALOGY.
THERE'S TWO SIDES AND WE GET
BEHIND ONE SIDE WOULD BE FOR
THAT SIDE AND MAYBE WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT INVESTED IN IT, BUT
WE STILL REFERRED ANYWAY AND
IT'S LIKE EASY FOR US BECAUSE
WERE HERE.
>> Michele: THIS IS THE FIRST
WERE WATCHING THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA, REAL-TIME
INTERVIEWS AND PICTURES.
I LOVE WHAT ZELENSKYY SAID ABOUT
THE U.N. AND I WANT YOU TO TELL
ME IF YOU KNOW WHO THIS IS.
I DISCOVERED THAT THE WORLD
SHOULD BE DIVIDED NOT INTO GOOD
AND BAD PEOPLE, BUT INTO COWARDS
AND NONCOWARDS.
95% OF COWARDS ARE CAPABLE OF
THE VIOLENT THINGS, LETHAL
THINGS AT THE MILDEST THREAT
ANYONE?
THE RUSSIAN WRITER.
[LAUGHS]
WE WERE THIS CLOSE.
>> Greg: I WAS TO SAY BUT
ANYWAY.
>> Michele: I THINK THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF COWARDS IN THE U.N.
AT A LEVEL HE SAID TO THEM.
WHAT ARE YOU ABOUT?
WHAT ARE YOU EVEN DOING TO HELP
HERE?
I THINK WE KNOW THAT IF YOU WANT
TO CHOOSE A SIDE OF THE OTHER,
I'M CHOOSING THE SIDE THEY GOT
ATTACKED.
I'M BACK IN THE SIDE BECAUSE
THEY DID NOTHING TO BRING THIS
ON, BUT WHAT IS THE U.N. EVER
DONE?
WHETHER THEY EXIST?
THEY GATHER, THEY DO THEIR
SPEECHES.
>> Greg: THE OCTAVE PIE ARE
WORKERS WHEN THEY COULD BE DOING
OTHER THINGS.
>> Michele: THE UNITED STATES
SPENT 11 AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS TO BE A MEMBER OF THE
U.N.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
AND WHY ARE THEY NOT DOING MORE?
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THEIR HUMAN
RIGHTS COUNCIL, THE SECURITY
COUNCIL WHO IS ON THESE
COUNCILS, CHINA --
HE HAD EVERY RIGHT TO BE ON
DIPLOMATIC AS IT WAS READ TO HIM
BECAUSE IT'S INSANE.
WE'VE SEEN THIS WITH YOU BEFORE,
WE SAW IT WITH HITLER, WE SAID
NEVER AGAIN AND HERE WE ARE.
>> Greg: YOU'RE THE BUSINESS
MIND HERE.
>> Dagen: HE BROUGHT ME IN
HERE FOR THAT I THOUGHT IT WAS
GONNA TELL SOME LADY JOKES AND
MAKE BRETT UNCOMFORTABLE.
[LAUGHS]
IT'S A SPIRITUAL REPUTATION.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU COULD DO
BOTH, A LITTLE BIT OF BUSINESS
EXPERTISE AND THE SOMETHING
REALLY CRASS AND DISGUSTING.
>> Dagen: OKAY, I COULD DO
BOTH.
>> Greg: HOW MUCH LONGER CAN
INVITE REBOOT AN END DO THIS
FINANCIALLY?
>> Dagen: AS MUCH AS HE WANTS
BECAUSE HE TAKE THAT ABOUT
BILLION DOLLARS A DAY FROM OIL
THAT'S BEING SOLD TO THE WEST
AND TO EUROPE.
AND THAT IS MONEY THAT'S GOING
STRAIGHT INTO HIS HAND TO KILL
UKRAINIANS AND TO WHICH THAT
WAR.
THAT IS WHY THE RESPONSE AND
IT'S ULTIMATELY JOE BIDEN A
COMPANY THAT ARE IN CHARGE OF IT
AND IT'S WHY IT IS LESS THAN
HAPLESS.
JILL BIDEN WANTS TO MAKE A CUTE
JOKE THAT THE RUBLE WAS TERMED A
RUBBLE.
ACTUALLY NO.
AND THUS NOT FUNNY GRANDPA.
BUT IT'S BACK TO WHERE IT WAS,
THE RUBLE IS BACK TO WHERE IT
WAS RIGHT ABOUT THE TIME THE
INVASION, IF NOT BEFORE BECAUSE
MORE MONEY IS GOING INTO RUSSIA
AND IS COMING OUT OF RUSSIA.
ONE MORE THING ABOUT THE MONEY
NATURAL GAS FLOWS INTO EUROPE
VIA UKRAINE ARE AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL THAT THEY'VE BEEN SINCE
THE WAR.
SO THE MONEY JUST KEEPS ROLLING
IN TO PICK UP ON SOMETHING.
>> Greg: WOULD BE DOING?
>> Dagen: EUROPE CAN CUT OFF
RUSSIA AND THEIR SHOWING --
THERE TRY TO FIND OTHER SOURCES,
SAUDI ARABIA, THEY TURNED THEIR
BACKS ON JOE BIDEN AND THEIR
ACTUALLY PUMPING LESS OIL THAN
THEY PROMISE.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN STEPPING UP TO
PRODUCE WHAT EUROPE MIGHT NEED,
NOT BUYING FROM RUSSIA.
AND JUST ONE MORE THING.
I'M IN A QUOTE, I WANT TO
WINSTON CHURCHILL.
MONEY TALKS, AND [BLEEP] WALKS.
AND THAT'S WHAT ZELENSKYY SAID.
>> Greg: TECHNICALLY CAN'T
WALK, UNDER NO.
YOU KNOW KAT YOU DOING A LITTLE
BIT OF A REASSESSMENT OF HOW
THINGS ARE GOING.
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC ARE YOU
PESSIMISTIC?
>> Kat: I'M ALWAYS PESSIMISTIC
BUT THAT.
I THINK THAT IS JUST ONE OF
THESE THINGS WHERE I THINK IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE A VIEW LIKE YOU
HAVE WHERE YOU WORRY ABOUT
EXTERNALITY.
WE TEND A FEW THINGS AT A
POLARIZED BINARY WAY.
AND IF YOU SAY SOMETHING LIKE
HEY YOU MIGHT BE CONCERNED ABOUT
GETTING MORE INVOLVED NEXT
SKILLET IN THE CONFLICT, SOMEONE
WILL SAY TO YOU WHAT IS YOUR
GRANDMA GOT SHOT OF THE HEAD
WITH A RUSSIAN BULLET?
I WOULD BE VERY UPSET.
WHAT YOU THINK, OF COURSE.
YOU CAN REALIZE HOW BRUTAL WHAT
IS HAPPENING, BUT ALSO REALIZE
THAT TAKING CERTAIN ACTIONS CAN
ESCALATE IT AND IT WORSE.
>> Greg: BUT THAT YOU CAN HAVE
THAT FEAR, THAT CONCERN CAN BE
PARALYZED IN ACTION.
I THINK THE FEAR OF NUCLEAR WAR
IS A THING THAT PEOPLE RELY ON
IT IS A REAL CONCERN, BUT WE
HAVE LIVED WITH THAT CONCERN FOR
DECADES.